hi everyone my name is rune wadhwa and
i'm the 2010 National Geographic Bee
delaware state champion if i can get a
free trip to anywhere in the world i
would go to France I would be France
because France is everything you could
possibly want big cities with many
attractions great places for outdoor
activities beautiful beaches and of
course good places to relax I would
first go to Paris and seaside sense of
the Eiffel Tower the Louvre Museum and
the Notre Dame Cathedral I would then go
up north to places on the northern coast
such as larvae and normandie these are
great places to relax after that I would
go to the south of France to beach
resorts such as Marcel and nice these
places have beautiful beaches under the
hot Europeans on and near the
Mediterranean waters being green is very
important for the environment it
reducing your carbon footprint and
energy consumption I reuse and recycle
whatever I can and turn off the tap
while brushing my teeth I also turn off
the TV when no one is watching also to
reduce your carbon footprint you can get
solar panels and to make clean energy
that comes from natural resources like
our Sun there are many ways to study for
the National Geographic Bee everyone has
their own style but this was mine I use
a multitude of resources such as games
the internet reference books atlases and
of course lots of geography trivia I
also use flash cards and notes for
harder stuff these are great ways to
memorize something that you're having
trouble with learning about the world is
my passion and I put in a consistent
effort year-round I feel that this is a
good way to study for the B because it
helps you cover every aspect of
geography
you